Christian Dubé, m'aider à voir,
Davide Gentile s'est rendu à
l'hôpital de Montréal pour
enfants. Vous allez voir, c'est
très clair,
ça ne va pas très bien.
♪ ♪ ♪
- L'hiver vient tout juste
d'arriver, mais les hôpitaux
pédiatriques sont débordés
depuis plusieurs semaines.
Beaucoup plus d'enfant
sont malades, leur immunité
semble moins bonne à cause
de la pandémie.
Dre LAURIE PLOTNICK, Hôpital
de Montréal pour enfants
- Moins bonnrcrcrce qu'ils n'ont
pas eu de rhumes pour développer
leur immunité, et les femmes
enceintes n'ont pas eu
d'anticorps pour protéger...
pour transmis à leur bébé.
- Malgououout, en début
de matinée, on profite ici
d'une rare accalmie.
- À l'urgence, ça peut vraiment
rapidement se détériorer,
la situation.
- Mais une heure plus tard,
les choses basculent : un enfant
est en danger, frappé par une
grave détresse respiratoire.
- Je pense qu'on va y aller
de l'avant avec une intubation.
- Une quinzaine de soignants
se précipitent à son chevet.
Dr ESLI OSMANLLIU, Hôpital
de Montréal pour enfants
- Ça prend des mains, ça
des cerveaux aussi autour de cet
enfant-là. Les patients qui sont
malades aussi de l'autre côté,
mais moins malades, vont devoir
attendre.
- Et tranquillement,
la salle datant, les chaises
se remplissent. Depuis quelques
semaines, l'attente peut aller
jusqu'à 12 heures et plusieurs
comme Caroline sont ici
parce qu'ils p p p pas
de médecin de famille.
CAROLINE DOLAN
- Non, c'est souvent
les urgences. Des fois,
on réussit à avoir un
rendez-vous dans une clinique
sans rendez-vous, mais souvent,
ça va être plus urgences.
- Ou d'autres comme Sarah
quvavavavavaient pas attendre
très longtemps.
SARAH MARTINEAU
- En appelant ce matin,
on me donnait un rendez-vous
mardi, mais moi, j'étaiscecececr
un docteur aujourd'hui,
sinon c'était l'urgence,
soit ce matin, soit cette nuit.
- La pression est forte,
tellement que des chambres
individuelles ont même été
transformées en chambre double.
Plusieurs enfants sont coincés
à l'urgence, faute de lits
ailleurs dans l'hôpital.
- Une vingtaine de patients
qui sont hospitalisés ici,
qui sont attente d'un lit
à l'hôpital, mais en raison
des étages qui sont tout à fait
pleins, des soins intensifs
aussi qui sont pleins,
de patients se ramassent
à rester à l'urgence.
- Les hôpitaux pour adultes
ont reçu l'ordre d'éviter
les transferts d'enfants
vers les hôpitaux pédiatriques.
- Oui. Oui, l'enfant est
en ce moment tdededededede, mais
on l'a stabilisé. Il est allé
aux soins intensifs.uiuiuiuiuiué
l'enfant, atteint d'insuffisance
respiratoire, mais avec
la saison de la grippe
qui approche, le personnel
est fatigué et bien des médecins
souhaitent qu'on recommence
à utiliser les masques,
à tout le moins dans
les espaces fermés.
- Mais je suis inquiet
pour les mois à venir. Il faut
vraiment que la population aussi
essaie de faire la part
e e e e e e et qu'on s'entraide
pour prendre soin
de nos enfants.
- Ici Davide Gentile,
Radio-Canada, Montréal